Charlie Munger was one of my greatest
heroes and he just recently passed away
at the age of 99 uh month and a half
away from turning a
[Music]
100 he lived one of the most exceptional
lives both in his personal success but I
would say more so in how much he was
willing to give back to others to help
others along the way and he embodied all
of the traits that he espoused in the
many speeches and talks and shareholder
meetings that he had over his 99y year
career and I want to share some of my
personal biggest takeaways from having
Charlie Munger as a hero that don't even
come close to the many gems of wisdom he
shared but are some of the ones that I
use on a regular basis so right off the
bat the first and biggest one is his
process of inverted thinking now he
purportedly claims that he's not the
first person to say this Einstein always
said invert always invert and so Charlie
wood was a huge history buff and loved
living in the past and reading
autobiographies of the smartest people
who had ever walked the Earth and a lot
of his thinking processes were
formulated from seeing how those people
thought and he passed it along to people
like you and me and inverted thinking is
simply taking a very hard problem so if
you said hey I want to grow my business
trying to grow a business is in some
ways more complex and difficult than
saying if I were to destroy my business
in as few moves as possible what would I
do and so then thinking well if I wanted
to absolutely destroy my business I
would do this first and then I would do
this second and then I would do this
third and then I would do this fourth
and you create that list and all of a
sudden what's interesting about it is
that we have such a stronger ability to
find threats and negatives in our
environment then we do positives and so
it's like if I were to ask you hey tell
me 10 things you're grateful for you
might be like um well I right now if I
said tell me 10 things tell me about 10
problems you have in your life you could
probably rattle off a 100 without
breaking a sweat it's because we we're
way more wired to find threats in the
environment than find good things now
using that engine we apply it to a
business or personal setting or any
complex problem and say okay I'm going
to find all the ways I'm going to
destroy my business and then you invert
it and so if for me to destroy my
business I would make sure that I would
never let anyone know about my stuff
okay well then what would I do to invert
that I would let as many people as human
possible know about my stuff if I wanted
to destroy my business I would make sure
that we had uh terrible product so that
anybody who bought it would immediately
think it was awful and tell all their
friends that it sucked and leave bad
reviews okay so what's the opposite of
that I want to have something that's
exceptional that as soon as people get
it they love it they tell the friends
how great it is and then they leave
positive reviews right and you can go
down the list and start thinking okay if
I wanted this negative thing to happen
what would I do you say that and then
you invert it and for whatever reason
you get completely different answers
than you would trying to think of it in
the positive and I have done this
Einstein did it Munger did it they're
way more successful than I am in many
ways and so it is a process that I've
used in so many different parts of my
life Charlie said the the death of most
people is liquor is the Three L's liquor
leverage and ladies uh
so and so I'm not saying uh you avoid
liquor ladies and leverage but to some
degree that's pretty much what they did
uh they never took on excessive debt
beyond what they could very reasonably
cover they uh they didn't fander uh like
obviously Warren had two wives he had
his own setup but they weren't running
through many many women um and Charlie
was pretty adamant about this he said
I've never seen somebody whose life was
better by including drugs and alcohol on
them next thing I got from Charlie is
his absolute obsession with Simplicity
and his abhorrence of complexity and
things that seem too complicated
Charlie's most common response to Deals
was too hard and I think that that shows
so much humility in how he'd approach
he's one of the greatest investors of
all time and still the majority of deals
that came in and he was brilliant he
would just say too hard and so to me
it's not like obviously he could think
about it harder and figure it out or he
probably did already know what it was
but it just showed his absolute
commitment to Simplicity and I think
Warren was uh quoted by saying we want
to have businesses that are so wonderful
that an idiot could run it and then have
wonderful people run it instead and I
think about that a lot with the
businesses that we want to invest in and
even the business models that we choose
to pursue because often times you have
strategic decisions you need to make in
your business you're like okay well
there's this slightly more complicated
thing or this simple thing which one
should I do well often times if it's
simpler at scale it becomes complex and
complexity at scale becomes impossible
and so he takes the path of leas
resistance when it comes to some of
these decisions and so I guess Charlie
gave me a lot of permission to just say
too tough too hard for me and I think a
lot of times letting yourself off saving
all that mental energy of trying to make
an impossible or complex task work
rather than just saying I'm I'm opting
out I'm going to I'm going to follow the
easier path because at the end of the
day we're the ones who choose how hard
we want our lives to be and so he's like
yeah well if it's my choice then I just
choose the easy life if a hard way to
make money easy way to make money and
you could choose either one then why
would you not choose the easy one the
next thing I learned from a concept that
I remember as unique expensive sticky
air managed by an owner and so basically
that was their breakdown of the perfect
business so unique in that it has a
brand or something unique about it that
makes it difficult for other people to
copy this is when they talk about a
competitive mode and so brand being one
of the most obvious ones that you can
use unique expensive so expensive and
air actually are paired together which
is you want something that you can buy
for a penny and sell for a dollar not
buy for 90 cents and sell for a dollar
right you want to have a lot of margin
in whatever it is that you sell so that
you can make more gross profit so that
you can reinvest in the business Andor
take distributions as an owner so the
sticky part is getting something that
people will buy again and again and
again and again and so that's both
recurring and also reoccurring and so if
you look at their portfolio they have
recurring businesses like insurance but
they also have reoccurring businesses
like Coca-Cola so you probably have
bought Coca-Cola products knowingly or
unknowingly and you probably have never
thought that you're on a Coca-Cola
subscription but every time you buy a
power raid or you get a Sprite or you go
to the gas station you grab a drink or
you go to a restaurant and you ask for a
Diet Coke when you're there all of those
even though they are reoccurring to you
they are recurring to the parent company
because that restaurant or that gas
station regularly buys the same amount
of coke even though you're not the one
who's quote on the subscription and the
further up the distribution chain you go
the more reliable those purchases become
and so they both wanted unique things
that no one else could copy that you
could charge a lot of money for that
don't cost a lot and so the air piece is
also low capital expenditure like you
don't have to keep pouring money back
into the business in order to keep it
competitive sticky is that you want
people to love the product such that
they want to keep buying it again and
again and so those are the actual
economics of the business the second
part of the business was who's running
it right they said they want a business
that's so wonderful that an idiot
couldn't ruin it and then hire a
wonderful person to run it and so when
they talk talk about wonderful people
they' I've pieced these pieces together
from the the talks that both of them
have given but it's that they want
someone who acts like an owner they want
them to behave as though 100% of their
net worth is in the business that
they're invested in and they cannot sell
a stock ever and so when you get someone
to think in that in that way then you
get someone who was going to make
ultimately very long-term decisions
that's the only thing they're actually
indexing for by setting the incentives
in that way you have to imagine all of
your net worth is in the one stock that
you're running of the company and you
can never sell it now what do you do is
decision- making and that's the right
decision for the business and so I think
one of the other things that Charlie's
been so good at is he just knows what
enough is enough he said I don't need
the last dollar and I'm roughly
paraphrasing there but basically he
believed that deals should are either
good and obvious or bad and obvious he
said you shouldn't need an Excel sheet
to figure out if you're going to make
money it should be clear that you're
going to make money on the deal and so
he didn't need to Big borrow and steal
and negotiate and chisel away the other
person's slice of the pie to get a few
more percentage points he said either
I'm going to make a lot of money or I'm
not and so he was willing to leave meat
on the bone uh or some room for other
people at the table so that one other
people could make money but I think the
long-term thing is that those people
would want to do deals with him again
because imagine if you have if you're
always known as a super tough negotiator
that doesn't leave anything for anybody
else it's like you might get that one
deal but no one's going to call you
first you're always going to be called
as a last resort rather than the first
person they call and the amount of
benefit you get from being everyone's
first call rather than their last call
probably can't be accounted for for
entire lifetime compounded with that
kind of reputation so another one this
is a big one that I learned from Charlie
was actually the importance of brand and
so if you look at their most recent and
if you think about them as investors in
my opinion they only got better because
your discernment as a decision maker
just only improves with time as long as
your mental faculties are there and
Charlie has shown I mean till the day he
died that he had all of his meal mental
faculties he did the shareholder meeting
was still just smart as a whip and there
for 6 hours answering questions and and
and putting people in their PL people
don't seem to get that point have any
idea why Charlie war and if people
weren't so often wrong we wouldn't be so
rich and if you look at their largest
most recent investment it's been apple
and so right now over half of at least
the last time I checked half of
Berkshire hathway is just Apple half
huge why were they willing to buy a
technology company when they normally
didn't buy into technology overall it
was because they saw the brand of apple
as the big strategic Moe they saw that
Apple could keep creating products and
they had such a loyal audience of people
who would just buy anything that they
put out that they felt the likelihood
that this company would be able to
charge above average prices for average
products for the extended for for the
foreseeable future was high and so they
were willing to bet a huge amount of
money on that company and they did and
they were right yet again and so seeing
that the companies they buy really are
Brands you know Ben Bridges Jewelers you
look think about C's candies think about
Dairy Queen you think about about Geico
these are all companies that are wholly
owned by Berkshire hathway and they were
willing to buy those companies because
they saw that they had a strategic moat
and it wasn't because they had some
novel business thing it was because of
the brands that those companies had
built and when I saw that them as
investors and me as a business owner in
different hats both saw the importance
of brand to me was very confirming on my
investment now in trying to build the
brand that I am so this is a big one uh
Charlie talked about living within your
means a lot and it's such an obvious
thing but if you had all the rules of
money written in order you could follow
just rule number one and never need
money ever again which is if you always
spend less than you earn you will
literally never need money you wouldn't
even need your savings because you would
always spend less than you earn so you
would never lack for money it's rule
number 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 because like
you can't even do investing where rule
number one is don't lose money rule
number two is don't forget rule number
one well you couldn't do that unless you
spent less than you earned and so like
rule zero is spend less than you earn
and what's crazy is that so many people
are trying to find Advanced and
complicated trading and investing
tactics when they haven't even mastered
balancing their
budget and so he had such such an
emphasis on doing the fundamentals that
I think just his his repeated emphasis
of that and just now paired with my own
experience having
grown relatively large companies I mean
over the last three years we've added
100 million in Revenue organically from
the companies we have in the portfolio
so I feel relatively confident talking
about it um we don't do anything
complicated ever all we do is
continually try and simplify the
business and do the fundamentals
everywhere all the time that's it
because doing the fundamentals
everywhere all the time is already as
complicated as you can imagine doing
anything beyond that doesn't even happen
in reality and so if you do the
fundamentals everywhere all the time you
become an advanced business owner yeah I
mean Warren and and and Charlie both
talk about learning from the mistakes of
others so the next point that I would
say I grab from both him and Warren was
learning from the mistakes of others you
know they say uh a dumb person makes
their own mistake and then repeats it a
smart person learns from their mistakes
a wise person learns from the mistakes
of others and so you can live multiple
lifetimes of lessons simply by allowing
other people to share their lessons and
their mistakes with you and then taking
the lesson without the scar and so
honestly that's why I make the I mean
this channel is so that I can transfer
as many of the scars rather the lessons
that I got without the scars to everyone
in mosy nation um but I feel like I've
learned so many of those lessons from
Uncle Charlie and Uncle Warren um that
I've just been able to apply into a
modern-day uh business environment uh
just in my own life I think one of the
one of the most understated things that
I learned from Charlie was that despite
being one of the best investors of all
time I think the thing that made him one
of the best isn't necessarily his
financial return there are other
investors who have achieved higher
returns than he and waren have now
obviously from absolute returns because
they've been doing it for so long uh
they have one of the biggest portfolios
of all time but Charlie's net worth was
only a few billion dollars and I say
only as though it's not a lot of money
of course it was but he could have made
a lot more if he so chose to
but he said over and over again that he
never wanted to make money he just
desperately wanted to be independent he
said he just overshot and I think about
that a lot when it comes to what things
I'm optimizing for because it's so easy
to get caught in the race of more of
just always wanting more and never
having enough and I think probably the
single greatest thing that I would say I
observe from Charlie was that he knew
when enough was enough and that he'
accomplished his objective which was to
be free and independent and to just do
whatever he wanted whenever he wanted
with whomever he wanted and I think that
in a lot of ways the way he lived was an
ideal life he he he spent his time doing
the thing that he was exceptional at
with the person that he probably cared
the most about in the world which is
Warren his closest friend they never
argued once in their entire relationship
per my understanding and what better of
a life could you ask for and so I think
when I think about his life I see that
as such a wonderful model to go after
and and I will be eternally grateful for
the contribution that he had unknowingly
uh to my
life